Galaktoboureko and baklava are traditional
Greek desserts.
Although several European and Middle Eastern
countries have versions of baklava, most
consist of phyllo pastry filled with nuts
drenched in honey or syrup.
Galaktoboureko is phyllo filled with custard
and coated with sweet syrup.
This variety of baklava called Berma is made
not with phyllo dough like classic baklava,
but with kataifi shredded wheat dough.
Berma like classic phyllo baklava contains
whole pistachios, never pistachio powder.
This Berma chef pours granulated sugar over
the pistachio kernels.
Next, he sprinkles rosewater.
Although this ingredient is optional.
Then syrup made with sugar, water, cinnamon
and nutmeg as well as lemon to prevent the
sugar from later crystallizing.
He mixes by hand to thoroughly coat the
kernels.
The kataifi is made of all purpose flour,
milk and water.
The chef lays out a section of dough, then
takes a handful of pistachio filling and
places it on the dough, forming a line
running down the middle for a Burma loaf this
size. The filling is about an inch wide and
high.
He folds the end closed and rolls the dough
at an angle down the length of the Burma,
tightly encasing the filling as he goes.
At the end, he folds the opposite end
closed.
It takes a Burma chef months to perfect this
technique.
He places it on a tray to air dry for 24
hours to ensure the dough maintains its old
shape. Unlike classic baklava, which is
baked, Burma is fried, and the risk of
burning the pistachios makes this the most
technically challenging type of baklava to
make. The chef fries the loaves for three
minutes in oil heated to around 350°F,
turning them once per minute.
He lets the oil drain off for half an hour.
Then he pours warm, caramelized sugar over
the loaves and lets them soak for 20 minutes.
The sugar to water ratio and the boiling
time of the caramelized sugar have to be just
right. Otherwise it will become either too
hard or too gooey when it cools.
After letting the excess drain off the
loaves rest for about three hours.
Then the chef rolls the loaf to flatten out
the bumps and slices it into equal pieces.
But if there's a protracted battle waging
between your sweet tooth and your willpower.
You've got plenty of time to work your way
through a box of Burma because it stays fresh
for two weeks.
To make galaktoboureko.
The chef begins with two ingredients milk
and semolina.
After bringing the milk to a boil, he
gradually adds the semolina while whisking
and lowering the temperature.
Once the mix thickens, he sets it aside to
cool.
In a separate bowl, the chef whisks eggs,
adds vanilla, then lemon or orange rind.
Other options are orange blossom or
rosewater extract.
He transfers the ingredients to an electric
mixer, adds butter and sugar.
Then he adds the semolina and milk mixture.
This mixture must be cool so that the eggs
don't cook.
Once everything is thoroughly blended, the
Galaktoboureko custard is ready.
The chef now turns his attention to the
phyllo dough.
He stacks 24 parchment, thin sheets of phyllo
and slices them into squares.
He places one scoop full of custard in the
center of each square.
The traditional Greek way is to roll the
squares or bake a large galaktoboureko in a
pan and then cut it into squares.
However, this chef folds over each square to
make Lebanese style triangles.
He douses the top with clarified butter
butter that's been boiled to separate out the
solids and leave just the oil.
Then he bakes the pastries for 45 minutes at
325°F.
The golden baked top shines thanks to the
clarified butter.
The chef cooks the same syrup he made for
the baklava.
Sugar water, cinnamon, nutmeg and lemon and
generously drizzles the mixture all over the
galaktoboureko as he sprinkles on cinnamon
for traditional flavor and some crushed
pistachios for decoration.
The annual apple harvest is just two months
long.
To keep apples fresh in storage for several
months, growers lower the store room oxygen
level to put the apples into hibernation.
Then they use machines called CO2 scrubbers
to absorb and remove the carbon dioxide gas
The apples give off.
This CO2 scrubber pulls air from the
airtight apple storage room through carbon
pellets, which absorb the CO2 gas molecules.
The machine then blows the CO2 free air back
into the room.
Workers build, the machines frame out of
tubular steel.
The frame supports all the components,
including two sealed vessels filled with
carbon pellets.
The first vessel starts absorbing CO2, a
process called scrubbing until its pellets
are saturated.
Then the second vessel takes over the
scrubbing.
The first vessel automatically kicks into a
regeneration cycle, which blows fresh air
through the pellets to remove the CO2
molecules and exhaust them out the building.
When the second vessel's pellets max out,
vessel one resumes scrubbing while vessel two
regenerates. To construct each vessel,
workers weld a steel sheet into a circular
shape, then weld on a base and a top ring.
The ring has holes along its perimeter for
bolting on a lid.
They use a ring template to make
corresponding holes in the lid, making the
exact center of each hole with a punch tool.
Then a worker mounts the lid on a fixture,
and following those marks uses an automated
steel punch to perforate the steel.
The vessels go to the paint booth for a coat
of powder paint.
Then into an oven to bake the paint.
When they come out, the vessels are ready to
be filled with carbon pellets and seal.
Once filled to the top workers lay in a
steel baffle.
Its holes evenly distribute air passing
through the vessel.
A worker then places a foam rubber gasket
around the perimeter.
And bolts on the lid tightly.
This seals the vessel and prevents the air
being blown through it from leaking out.
The sealed lid also prevents oxygen from
getting into the machine and from there into
the apple storage room.
Next, workers install the PVC piping that
feeds air through the vessels, along with two
blowers. One blower pulls air from the apple
storage room into the machine for scrubbing.
The other sends it back to the room after
scrubbing.
The airflow through the pipes is controlled
by valves which are wired to the machine's
electrical panel.
That electrical panel consisting of relays,
pumps, gas analyzers and a touch screen is
built in house in accordance with the
required electrical standards of the
customer's country.
The panel is wired to a computer which
controls the entire operation.
Then a worker installs an electrical box
into the machine's frame.
And he installs the electrical panel inside
the box.
Next, the worker connects the wires to the
valves, installs the touchscreen and hooks it
up to the computer.
The touchscreen lets the machine's operator
program oxygen and CO2 target levels specific
to the type of apple stored in the room.
This is critical as different varieties of
apples give off more CO2 than others.
How does it all work?
The grower stacks bins of apples in an
airtight storeroom.
A nitrogen generator feeds in nitrogen to
reduce the room's oxygen level to 1.8%.
When that happens, the nitrogen feed
automatically stops and the continuous CO2
scrubbing automatically begins.
Many growers have in-house labs which
conduct quality control tests on samples
taken from each lot of scrubbed apples
coming out of storage.
No apples would pass these tests after the
two month harvest season if not for the CO2
scrubbers. Co2 scrubbers lengthen an apples
freshness by about eight months, making it
possible to bite into crispy apples year
round.